welcome to the Skrillex game into this
video then zama net saree mahali know
something like that okay no no name I am
though let's see um yeah maybe the
Benoni for a change haven't played that
so often on video okay I'm trying to get
in Bishop g4 that is quite often a good
idea Queenie to is a very critical line
now if i remember correctly this Queenie
to hear now I think it didn't happen
okay I was immediately took on f3 to
make sure that nothing terrible is
happening to me there um yeah like 92 or
something just want to exchange the
bishop the c8 bishop is often the
problem pays a piece and the Benoni yes
it is doing you are close to nothing um
yeah just drew p8 yeah maybe now I can
just put it only five now or the night
yeah maybe he has Bishop g3 anthem and F
form this type of idea hmm 95 Bishop g3
I'm hmm maybe I can play g5 but this
weekend set 5 quite considerably okay
I'll just just protect it for the moment
the d6 bomb and then see what what I can
do maybe it's an idea to go Knight g4
five gain some space here if he plays
Bishop g3 I might have the idea to
harass the bishop with H for now why not
this looks like a playable position and
I could have taken you from actually why
didn't that take you for it was simply
possible Wow okay so um that's not good
overlooking this kind of simple stuff
okay my ideas to to have this age for
movie goes push-up g3 also I wanted to
have this opportunity I think I go for
that that's a good spot for the bishop
hmm is f 5m o 4 s is totally crazy f5 he
cannot take because II to hangs and
maybe I can play g5 at f/4 very
ambitious very ambitious but ok while
the Benoni is ambitious in the first
place so lets them let's try that and
here we go what's the idea I Bishop b2
probably and then I go F form hmm yeah
he can put the bishop on c3 now this
might be might be good for wider Bishop
d2f form bishops III
I'm probably should be five then ok it's
a very very young yeah very very
complicated and not so easy to tell I
wonder though okay maybe he wants to go
to f2 we haven't that possible certainly
mmm yeah should I take or not but they
don't know letting him take makes a
weird impression if i go to e5 I have so
many pieces welcome that want to go to
e5 so probably probably that's okay okay
yeah this to e5 and maybe the other
Knight to d7 covering b6 and so and
stuff okay he threatening to take their
not really i can do that anyway queen
bee three is a bit weird actually
because I thought that I thought that
white would go for before him 97 I can
do that d3 is hanging so you cannot take
b7 dough now I get this fantastic spot
only five for my night which is
completely yeah cannot detect it in any
way that's very nice maybe rook c8 now
you can overprotecting see file so that
I have after beef or even see form that
looks nice um maybe here do I want to
exchange Quincy I don't really know I
also have some attacking potential with
G foursome it's not clear
I want to go kingi 797 of it Isis I'm
not sure sure but undecided him I can
also really go for King side attack with
them let's say gee form okay now he's
playing this after all hmm well now
taking it as some easily allowing access
to to be seven in the other hand or
fatigue I don't and I must speed up him
on the other hand what I wanted to say
is that I'm very quick on the sea fowl
yeah rook c7 my intended move for some
problem he can take it and play Queen B
7 what's not so great actually often I
also like to didn't like to fight him
not not sure and what how to us in our
third yeah once is enough really they
simply don't get it boom some people I
just one offer its gritty enough if i
decline once i won't take it the move
after that okay i'm so giad why not take
let's take it check Queen takes on the
the back rank you
let's see Molly takes we can I can play
a queen ne7 to to cover both pawns next
move you could give this check here
actually Jack go here hmm i go to f
ather squeegee 7 which is not helping so
let's go down not sure what to make make
of this position here to be honest I can
I have this check now here but you can
pin me with 27 mm interesting I hear of
Queen g5 that's a good end game now
check
yeah my can I can keep my stuff
protected him checking a five if he
takes I get quite a number of free porns
or passed pawns check yeah I must be as
quick as possible check check check
check six seconds that's not much check
check check check wait for fence oh yeah
that was probably probably quite bad
this position at at one point or another
yeah I care I think I must have
misplayed it somewhere around here I
mean this must be really nice for like
with this night only five the time I'm
not sure really it's fantastic looking
piece but I'm not so sure what my plan
is that that's that's a problem really
he got in this before move and I'm not
sure what I should do probably it was a
wrong idea to capture probably it was
because I cannot hmm well let's say rook
c2 we're probably looks he too was bad
something like that and Roxy 70 I don't
know I mean this is not really too
convincing and see form yeah it looks
very nice but but what exactly is my
plan if he plays let's say rook c1 Roxy
to look see one Queen d4 tried to pick
this up I don't I don't know what I'm
going to
next I can think of moves like g4 but do
they help me I mean if i take it the g
fat is probably opening to White's
advantage very curious position hmm i
don't know maybe i should have done
something differently earlier chan of
this this wasn't great really i mean
here why this is probably a better in
some way but it wasn't clear to me
around here you offered the drawers but
i don't know it seemed that black also
should have some some chances and i
would drop their check we got this
position right yeah and he i didn't
really know what to do well night f7 I
expected Queen d7 or Quincy seven
something something like that but he
surprisingly went here and now traded
Queens which was very surprising because
I thought that this can only be good for
black maybe I'm wrong about that but
well okay these pawns are of course on
light square so that he has got some
some way to go go to go down but here
played this immediate break any i think
it was not really working king of six is
stronger yes this is stronger of course
yeah this wins outright i believe him
yeah this this is much much better okay
i didn't have much time but still this
just intends to pick it up and what is
black doing what is why doing against
that can play this move but here i can
even know just just take him
something like that is a pretty simple
win now in the game and we got at the
end we got to this I mean this is
probably also something where I can
improve yeah go over with the King and
not this one Jack King c6 is better yeah
okay I didn't have any time I then just
push the apron or what hmm no this is
this was right King e7 but exactly wise
King is seven strong I don't understand
it ah of course yes of course a ok well
mm-hmm 13 seconds and the ideas it
threatens king of aid to stop the porn
so King g7 and then you look at this I'm
much quick i am and here i am even check
checkmate having this direct checkmate
ok this would have would have been
better alright thanks for watching